of my favorite people and chris
confirmed that i said this that i called
him talented and funny with him
without him on hold yeah you said it not
fair literally he did that
right i mean i just i don't know why i
feel the need to prove myself
well he can beat you up because he's
absolutely jacked well i know he's
jacked yeah i understand that i see it
all the time because he's on everything
on fox that ken jong is on and he's
also or not stuff that you know he's on
and ken jong isn't
and he's also the host of abc's card
sharks he's one of our favorites joel
mchale back here on the rich island show
the host of fox's crime
scene kitchen wednesday nights at nine
eastern time how are you sir
how can i insult you now rich after that
very very
kind and a complimentary intro i don't
know what to say now well why would you
insult me what would that be i don't
know
it's the only tool i have in my bag
you're not you're you're you're you're a
warm man inside joel come on now
i know that for a fact yeah i have a
couple of shots of whiskey in me already
it's it's five o'clock somewhere for
sure
yeah somewhere over the atlantic ocean
my children
my children were very excited i was as
well to see the promos during
lego masters which is when are you to
appear on that wonder how come you
haven't been on that one yet joel
legolas i'm not on that uh
there's something must be done i think
ken jong blocked it because
uh he has to host 80
of everything on fox right i i have to
stay behind
and then you got will arnett that's
right you know he's the voice of batman
is very intimidating
uh my kids do love legos but right they
also love
cake see that transition is crime scene
kitchen everybody
that's why my kids love it they they
they they love cake too
they love seeing this sort of so so the
construct of this show
is is like is is basically you've got to
figure out
what's been cooked based on the clues
that have been left behind
and then cook it yourself right right uh
you find it's like looking for aaron
rodgers at mini camp
and topical
what are the clues did you find a thigh
pad or what did you see
uh maybe an arm guard what'd you find no
right uh
yeah there's a kitchen that something
happened there was something was baked
there
and then you bake you you get all that
evidence and then you bake a cake in
front of a dead body
i didn't see that part i didn't see that
part
what happened at that part that's the
after dark version
so then you you do it you do this
you think you bake what you think it is
there's a bunch of teams competing and
then you see
then then we all have to taste it and i
say have to in that i get to
yes uh 10 000 calories a day and then
they reveal
what it is and then you're like oh they
were close and you might win 100 grand
so um two things first of all you didn't
really eat
that much joel come on now ten thousand
i swear to you i swear to you on the
dead bodies in the crime scene kitchen
yes uh that i ate because you can't
because all these teams are making these
beautiful desserts and of course in some
cases
disaster and were eating raw eggs yes
because they screwed up
which did happen and was wonderful later
on for me
but uh i'm not kidding in that so you
can't just taste it and go
this is fine i ate them i mean they were
i i they i put in front of me i'm not
going to not eat them and
right so yeah we would lie i literally
would lie down
like two hours tasting i just it was
great
oh since your first gluten in years uh
hosting fox's crime scene kitchen is
essentially what you're saying
right uh yeah i've never had more energy
in my life i can't believe
how people live like this they just it's
not just
all cold cuts and you know hard-boiled
eggs you can have wonderful gluten it's
just
yeah sugar and but you then you have
curtis stone
who's as you probably know who curtis
stone is he's a celebrity
famous chef yes a very nice man who does
not own a comb
and then um yolanda gamp who is
literally known as the
beyonce of cakes and if you go on her
instagram they
they make no sense on this earth so
they're the real judges and i'm just
uh you know me i just i'm just there to
eat as much as i can
and then work out desperately for a few
hours
do you have like you're you're like uh
you're like
todd gurley or one of those uh or like
cutler in the nfc championship game a
few years
ago is there like a stationary bike for
you to keep warmed up
on on the side of the set yeah
yeah i have this stationary bike in
front of a mirror and i just
weep and like scream cry
while i work out and then and then it
smells when my kids walk in the gym it
smells like
somebody's roasting cookies so much
sugar is leaving my bloodstream
oh the the most self-loathing host on
fox joel mchale
uh crime scene kitchen uh and then we'll
get to card sharks
uh in a second so are you are you um
looking at the rogers holdout as a
seahawk fan
uh excited or or leery but be that
there but for the grace of the football
gods perhaps you go
in short order i joel look i
good qu i you look when that when the
whole russell wilson thing was going
down i was like oh this is just a
maneuver to get a better you know just a
better offensive line and then it kind
of got
furious and then i got scared and then i
went to my russell wilson altar
in my closet and prayed to it and said
please don't leave
uh and then that energy seemed to shift
over to aaron rodgers
which i i didn't put a curse or anything
but
he's not showing up for mini camp which
is
a little scary i guess it's this time of
year they have to have it but
uh like i'm never the guy i swear to you
i'm not the guy
that goes i'm glad that person's out
that means it's easier for us
i would like bring all the competition
because i'm always like the seahawks
will take on anybody and
so i it's really i don't know do you
think it's gonna he's gonna actually
not be on the team i don't think i think
when it's all said and done that that
that at some point humpty dumpty will be
put back together again that he is
enjoying you know like uh putting the
magnifying glass on the front office and
general manager if that's who is his
intended target appears to be
and just placing that magnifying glass
into the glaring
hot sun of the nfl media and letting it
just cook
the subject underneath that i think
that's basically what he's doing right
now
that's essentially the goal he's like
instagramming photos
from the glaring hot sun of one of the
hawaiian islands which i was like wow
this guy
is a baller he is not joking around he's
like me and miles teller are going to be
in the tide pool while you guys work
this
out
[Laughter]
essentially yes joel that is what he did
in his doing
but why not i i don't you wish you could
of course
like rick would you when you're in
negotiations for your show
yes exactly like i am i just sit but i
just have my phone in my pocket with my
kids going
dad can you come and play i'm like no i
might get a text from my agent i don't
know what's happening
my my my uh my version of it is probably
going with the other star of whiplash
like jk simmons and hanging out at like
a golf range
i don't have that sort of flash that
rogers has
maybe you know what i mean like i don't
know if i've got that and plus i don't
have the ability to pull up next time
how about the next time you negotiate
you and i will just go down to cabo
and i'll take a bunch of photos of you
and we'll just we'll just have a great
time
all right how does this weekend sound
great
are you free this weekend actually
uh if it's saturday night i'm vaccinated
let's do it let's do it yes there's lots
going on i've got a lot to catch you up
on joel it'll be a lot of fun uh
crime scene kitchen airing wednesday at
nine eastern time
on fox and then card sharks you grew up
watching card sharks right like the rest
of us
this is so cool man me yeah are you
talking to me of course uh
yeah uh enormous i thought of course
you're interviewing me and i'm like wait
are
you
hold on a minute i've got ken jong in my
pocket wait a minute there he is
he's everywhere he's even hosting this
interview dang it damn it
yeah i know i did and i i loved all
those like the match game the dating
game
uh sale of the century uh press your
luck i watched all that stuff
and so to bring back hard sharks you
know with when
you're just it's just a high-low game
it's about as good as my like that's how
good i am in vegas is a high-low game
so it's it's but the stakes really do go
bananas and i watched a woman walk away
with like
hundred thousand dollars and she was
like my life has changed forever and i
said
well you could make a couple of mistakes
in the next few days and it'll
be right back to normal oh gosh no
you're not supposed to tell somebody
who's won that much money that the nice
parting gift for them
is doom and gloom that's just you can't
do that joel but
i'm the only host yeah i'm the only game
show host where i go and
after taxes
tell him what he's won a massive tax
bill
good luck and uh once we you get through
california emissions
that will be your car thanks for that
yeah i think i think you need to
workshop it a little bit joel i'll be
honest but uh it's funny we got our our
social media grand maester to my right
tj jefferson was on the price is right
and it was one of the most exhilarating
moments in the history of this show
because it happened live in the second
hour
when his month-long tape delay finally
aired and our
hearts were thumping and um
him walking away with just a ping-pong
table and a popcorn machine has been
nothing but fun for us since then
it's been great oh yeah do you taunt him
with what he could have had in the
showcase showdown
oh gosh do you want to tell him tj shut
up well joel teacher
well joel i i could have in a perfect
world i could have walked away
with not only that popcorn maker and the
ping pong table
but a new car two electric bikes
a trip to florida that was that one
really hurt yeah uh
a telescope and um oh yeah
two harley-davidson motorcycles and also
whatever
the uh whatever katie his his his uh
opponent in the showcase showdown
whatever she bit on too which is another
car
and other items because all he had to do
is bet one dollar because she went over
as well
and he walked away with nothing uh
i i'm speechless
i rich i would just
[Laughter]
harley davidson what's the cheapest
harley davidson you've ever
just guessed right now there you go i
gotta ask you this what do you think
all right i hate to tell you one dollar
no
that's why i love joel
you know like when someone's in a
divorce and they just like
when the wife is pissed and she's like
i'm getting rid of all your stuff and
she's like
here take the bike for a dollar take all
the other stuff it's
five bucks there's always clothes take
for free you know what i mean okay so
how much is the harley davidson
like the cheapest harley davidson take a
guess i mean do you know this sort of
grant
harley-davidson's he bid forty thousand
dollars in a trip to florida he was way
over
drew carey was smiling and everything
like that what's drew carey think when
something like that double over speaking
is a just a
comedian turned game show host like you
are now what do you sit there and think
when somebody just totally blows it
on the air you must be like if you're me
or drew carey you're going
i think i need another shot of espresso
i wonder if my i wonder if my fam when
my
my family i'll be having dinner with
them tonight we're going to go over
uh but yeah i i get i feel terrible
i really do feel terrible because there
was a couple people that bet everything
and they turn the card over and they get
nothing nice and they don't even get a
ping pong table or anything
so there there is a i mean obviously
it's a game not everybody can win it's
just how it is
uh but uh yeah it's it's tragic but the
good news is it's not like you had that
stuff
before right exactly
it's just like the world you walked in
you were born in with nothing and now
you're leaving here with nothing
just like that like the game show is
called foreclosure
that was my divorce taking your stuff so
that's good right you can walk out for
the same
oh my gosh plus someone on youtube said
i was too big for those harleys anyways
oh
come on don't listen to those no he's
saying they were smaller but oh i see
what you're saying okay very good
uh yeah okay you know what that you know
it's a good thing you didn't get that
crime scene kitchen crime scene kitchen
airing wednesday at nine eastern time on
fox and maybe we should pitch a show
what did del tufo just eat
after that and maybe we can host that
together because it seems like it's just
as much of a mystery
what do you think yeah let's pitch it
well the examination process is going to
be pretty great
uh well that's what ken jong's in charge
of because that's part of his you know
formula he just heard that he just heard
it now yeah he's going to host it he
just pitched it and host he's already
he's already taped the pilot dang it
joel congrats on
yet another show and killing it as well
you as as you always do always enjoy
chopping it up with you you're the best
thanks the call brother well
uh rich eisen has the velvety fog voice
that i love
to listen to because it not only suits
you but it keeps you awake
thank you i do both a shot of espresso
thank you joel appreciate it you take
care
thank you and go see hawks
just like boy he's just like russ go
hawks out the door
there you go right here take care about
it joel mchale everybody right here
crime scene kitchen airing wednesday at
nine eastern on fox
card sharks premieres next week next
wednesday june 16th
10 eastern on abc hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here